[Música]
para mí México Había sido un país
relativamente Pacífico de violencias
soterradas o contenidas una infancia en
la época del Pri un país muy autoritario
pero que contenía precisamente esas
violencias
el poder la violencia y México son
piezas angulares de las historias de
Jorge volpi pero para su libro partes de
guerra el aclamado escritor escogió un
nuevo escenario la frontera que separa
su país de Guatemala en la localidad de
frontera Corozal Jorge volpinos cuenta
una muerte ficcional basada en sus
propias investigaciones sobre los niños
asesinos y en esta novela policíaca Los
detectives son neurocientíficos que
tratan de entender los orígenes de la
violencia durante la última edición de
la feria del libro de Bogotá conversamos
con él de su proceso de escritura de sus
obsesiones literarias y de sus
esperanzas para México dos repeticiones
Muchas gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros en las veinticuatro
encantado de estar aquí un pueblo
mexicano a la frontera con Guatemala
adolescentes asesinos neurocientíficos
un poco pedantes y la búsqueda le da
origen de la violencia en los y en sí
mismo Esos son los ingredientes
principales de Tu última novela partes
de guerra y se siente que con esta
historia lograste desarrollar temas
complejos de manera completa mientras
que cuentas que fue el libro que más
rápido escribiste como hiciste eso Bueno
la verdad es un libro que es producto de
la pandemia antes de eso había me había
costado trabajo tener tiempo para
escribir los últimos años pero bueno de
pronto en el encierro pude escribir una
novela y un libro de cuentos que han
aparecido ahora pues en otras tras otro
y tenía la obsesión de mucho tiempo por
un lado Describir una novela con
neurocientíficos como protagonistas y
por el otro también me había interesado
mucho el tema de los niños violentos de
los niños que pueden convertirse en
asesinos y de pronto en la pandemia
pareció que estas dos historias podían
unirse en una misma novela
y explicas que la neurociencia hace
parte de tu vida desde hace mucho tiempo
es un tema que te interesa desde hace
mucho tiempo entonces dado el hecho que
las almas científicas suelen investigar
y prepararse mucho cuéntanos cómo te
preparaste para escribir este libro
bueno en efecto llevo varios años
investigando leyendo encontrándome con
neurocientíficos y con temas de
neurociencia escribió un pequeño libro
sobre neurociencia y literatura que se
llama leer la mente hace unos años he
dado varios cursos y ahora estoy
volviendo a escribir sobre temas de
neurociencia y literatura
Pues creo que Pues todos esos años
digamos de lecturas de encuentros de
diálogo con neurocientíficos terminaron
por reflejarse en esta novela
[Música]
entonces mira este documentales no sé
cómo cómo fue también es una es algo que
me había obsesionado por alguna razón
desde hace mucho entonces iba siguiendo
casos a lo largo del tiempo entonces más
que investigar para esta novela igual
Fue como un proceso de muchos años de
Ver casos reales en México y en otras
partes y a partir de ahí pues ya
imaginar este caso concreto este caso en
un escenario bien particular
frontera Corozal un territorio Atrapado
entre México y Guatemala hay que hace
parte del camino de los migrantes que
suenan con su vida hasta Estados Unidos
es un lugar que ella conocías porque lo
elegiste para partes de guerra Bueno
tengo que decir que fue casi casual yo
quería simbólicamente que la novela
pasara en la frontera sur y no en la
frontera norte que para México ha sido
siempre tan simbólica y donde los
mexicanos siempre hemos sido un poco
víctimas frente a la frontera Sur que se
ha convertido en un lugar de paso muy
fuerte para migrantes centro y
sudamericanos e incluso de otras partes
en donde ahora México se convierte en
parte de la política migratoria Estados
Unidos con expulsiones con
encierros con maltrato y violaciones de
Derechos Humanos quería que fuera esa
frontera y luego quería simbólicamente
que fuera el otro río no el río Bravo en
el norte sino el usumacinta que divide
México de Guatemala en el sur Entonces
no lo escogí un poco al azar estaba
viendo Qué pueblos y lugares había en la
frontera en la frontera
dudé entre uno finalmente elegí este
casi por eufonía del nombre y luego
pensaba ir ahí antes de escribir la
novela pero justo vino la pandemia
entonces terminó siendo al revés escribí
el libro y luego fui a frontera colosal
y ahí pues me tocó ya confrontarme con
la realidad confirmar algunas cosas
corregir otras en un lugar que no deja
de ser muy interesante y la atmósfera de
este lugar como la imaginabas durante la
pandemia mientras estaba describiendo
Cuando llegaste allá como te sentiste
fue cerca de lo que habías hecho muchas
cosas que se parecían O sea yo por
ejemplo imaginaba Cómo serán los niños
que era Quizá lo que más me intrigaba en
este lugar
un lugar que está muy lejos de cualquier
centro urbano un lugar relativamente
pobre
con muchas carencias
y al mismo tiempo donde nuestra época
todos los niños parecen estar conectados
con el centro del mundo a través de los
teléfonos celulares de los computadores
de bolsillo que seguimos llamando así y
lo imaginé así y en efecto en cuanto
llegué una de las primeras imágenes fue
ver este pequeño pueblo donde solo está
pavimentado la escuela pública todo lo
demás es terracería donde las casas la
mayoría son de madera de lámina donde
hay animales domésticos por todas partes
O sea que tiene un aire de pueblo remoto
pero donde de inmediato vi a dos niñas
de las edades de mis protagonistas cada
una con su teléfono inteligente Pues
claro eso fue digamos de confirmar y
luego bueno partes geográficas partes
del habla que tuve que corregir Ya
estando en el lugar para los lectores
que no son mexicanos o que tal vez no
conocen también el contexto de extrema
violencia que vive México pues tuvo la
trata de de manera muy clara y muy
directa en el libro hablas de la
violencia en México como de una epidemia
y también hablas de esta guerra que nos
llamamos guerra por las cifras que
podrían ser lo que tú dices cifras de
una guerra civil
crees que hay una solución a esta
situación en México yo siempre creo que
debe haber soluciones y yo no creo que
los mexicanos o los colombianos seamos
más violentos que el resto del mundo ha
habido épocas de calma épocas de
violencia
sociedades que han sido muy violentas
como Francia España y que luego se han
convertido en sociedades pacíficas y
Igualmente puede pasar al revés entonces
yo espero que logremos no sé si en mi
generación o la siguiente cambiar las
condiciones para que México vuelva a ser
una sociedad mucho menos violenta y uno
de de tus personajes al principio del
libro incluso dice como científicos
estamos obligados a hacer algo por este
país tú como escritor como artista
también esa obligación Pues sí también
le he sentido los últimos diez años en
México estuve trabajando en áreas
públicas culturales Me parece que la
cultura es efectivamente un derecho para
todos y que además puede tener una
incidencia poderosa en la sociedad se
fue el trabajo que desarrollé durante
esos diez años primero en el festival
Cervantino luego en la Universidad
Nacional autonomía de México y ahora
estoy de vuelta viviendo en España de
nuevo Pero sigo convencido de que la
literatura y el arte es un instrumento
de transformación social bueno partes de
guerra es un libro sobre el origen de la
violencia pero también sobre sensaciones
y sentimientos la lucha entre el cerebro
y el corazón por ejemplo tiene un lugar
central a través del dicho el corazón
tiene sus razones que la razón ignora
estas metáforas estas imágenes te ayudan
cuando estás escribiendo Sí esta es una
novela que fue para mí muy emocional la
escribí muy rápido
menos intelectual que realmente
emocional Y creo que eso se nota en el
libro y es parte central también del
tema del libro es una novela sobre yo
sentí sobre la lucha contra el olvido el
nuestro y el de nuestros seres queridos
No quiero contar toda la trama del libro
obviamente eso lo dejo para los sectores
Pero al final del libro tu narradora
dice esta frase te rescató de la muerte
porque no hay fuerza más poderosa que el
olvido Jorge sientes que la literatura
es tu manera de luchar contra el olvido
sí la literatura además de otras
funciones tiene la de luchar contra el
olvido
no estamos programados para recordarlo
todo está hecho el cerebro necesita el
olvido para poder seguir funcionando y
para poder subir Sobreviviendo y por lo
tanto Hay que ser un esfuerzo de memoria
sobre todo en Casos de violencia extrema
como las que se viven en México o en
Colombia Muchas gracias Jorge encantado
y gracias a ustedes por su confianza
sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en
France